قالت الولايات المتحدة إنه
ستكون هناك عواقب وخيمة على بيلاروسيا
إذا تم شن هجوم على أوكرانيا
من أراضي بيلا الروسية بنفسك
أو من قبل الجيش الروسي ، هل ما زلت تدعم
أه روسيا في طريقها نحو أوكرانيا ،
هل ما زلت تعتقد أننا ذاهبون إلى
هاجم أوكرانيا من هنا أو هل
تغلبت بالفعل على هذه العقبة الذهنية
يا سيدي ، لا يتعلق الأمر بما أعتقد أنه
يتعلق بما تقوله الولايات المتحدة تقول
الولايات المتحدة
إن هناك تهديدًا حقيقيًا
لهجوم من الأراضي الروسية أو
الأراضي البيلاروسية تجاه أوكرانيا.
اتفاق بين روسيا البيضاء
وروسيا
، شكلنا هنا
عمليا مجموعة روسيا البيضاء الموحدة ، وهي جيش موحد كما
يمكنك
القول وهذا هو موقفنا الرسمي ،
يرجى أخذ ذلك في الاعتبار لأننا
نأخذ في الاعتبار موقفك
وحول موضوع أوسع ما هو  أنت
تفعل هنا على بعد
آلاف الكيلومترات
ماذا عن خبرائك في أوكرانيا
قواتك في بولندا في
ليتوانيا ، لاتفيا إستونيا ،
ماذا تفعل  عليك أن تفعل هنا على بعد
آلاف الكيلومترات